[Music]  enjoying your new permafrost Olaf I'm  just living the dream honor oh how I  wish this could last forever hmm  and yet change mocks us with their  beauty what's that  forgive me maturity is making me poetic  tell me you're older and thus  all-knowing do you ever worry about the  notion then nothing is permanent  no you I can't wait until I'm agent like  you so I don't have to worry about  important things the past is not what it  seems  you must go north find the truth I'm  going with you honor no excuse me I  climb to the North Mountain survived a  frozen heart and saved you from my  ex-boyfriend so promise me we do this  together okay I promise  Hey  need to find the answers about the past  I believe in us more than anyone or  anything Rosen - it's a whole putting us  some mortal danger gonna be a regular  thing rated PG tickets available now  [Music]